hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math a
lot less stressful so in this lesson
what we're going to talk about is how to
write conic sections in standard form by
completing the square
so we know that conic sections are 1
conic sections are basically two cones
okay like this okay and and at this
vertex and they keep expanding out like
this okay upwards downwards forever and
ever but what a section is you take like
a plane and you cut through these cones
and depending on how you cut through
these cones you know you might get a
parabola if you cut it like this you
might get a circle you know if you cut
through and it cuts through both of them
you might get a hyperbola if you cut
through on an angle like this you'll get
a line if you cut right through here
you'll get a point you know so cut on an
angle like this so get an oval or an
ellipse so you're probably already
familiar with conic sections but in this
video what we're going to talk about is
how to rewrite them in the standard form
so they're easier to graph and easier to
work with okay so let's get right into
the first example here 9x squared plus
4y squared minus 36 X minus 24 y plus 36
equals 0 so the first thing we want to
analyze is what type of conic section is
it well you can see that there's an x
squared term in a y squared term if
there was just an x squared term but not
a y squared term or vice-versa we would
know that it's a parabola because we
have an expert in a Y squared term and
they're the same sign meaning they're
both positive or they were both negative
okay we know that it can't be a
hyperbola it has to be a circle or an
ellipse but because the coefficients in
front of the x squared + y squared term
are different okay but still the same
sign we know it's an ellipse so that's
how you can narrow it down so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to group the XS
together I'm going to group the Y's
together so let's take a look so we've
got 9x squared - 36 X okay plus 4y
squared - 24 y
equals negative 36 I'm just going to
move the 36 to the other side of the
equation just to get it out of the way
now we're going to do is we're going to
group these together the axes and the
Y's and we're going to factor out the
leading coefficient so if you factor out
a 9 here what we're gonna have is x
squared minus 4x and if we factor out a
4 here we're gonna be left with y
squared minus 6y equals a negative 36
okay now what we're gonna do is we're
gonna complete the square and we do that
by taking half of the coefficient in
front of this middle term here so half
of negative 4 is negative 2 negative 2
squared is positive 4 okay now what I
want you to recognize is that because
it's in parentheses it's actually 9
times 4 that I added out of thin air
okay 36 to the left side of this
equation I have to add 36 to the right
side to keep it balanced okay so let me
just do that right here plus 36 over
here half of negative 6 is negative 3 we
square that we get 9 4 times 9 is 36
again if I add 36 out of thin air to the
left side I have to add 36 to the right
side to keep it balanced okay so far so
good
so now we're going to factor this and
the way that we've set it up because we
completed the square is that this
becomes a perfect square and one thing
that I tell students all the time is
that you can always look at this middle
coefficient and just take half of that
quantity so if it's positive 4 this
would be positive 2 its negative 4 it's
just going to be negative 2 if you want
to verify this just go ahead and write X
minus 2 times X minus 2 foil it out
multiply it out and you'll see you get
back the original but this is just a
little shortcut same thing over here
what you can do is take half of negative
6 so that's going to be y minus 3 the
quantity squared equals these 36 is
canceled out and we're just left with 36
okay now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to divide everything by 36 because
ellipses we want them to equal one so
I'm just going to divide everything by
36 36 and so you can see this reduces to
X minus 2 squared over 4 and y minus
three squared over 9 equals one so now
it's in the standard form okay for an
ellipse and you can check out my video
on ellipses for graphing and identifying
the key points of ellipses but let's
look at another completing the square
example to put this conic section into
its standard form we've got some larger
numbers here I might have to go to the
calculator to make this a little bit
easier on us but let's do the same thing
let's group the Y's together let's group
the XS together and so on but before we
do that let's analyze what type of conic
section we're working with here so we
notice there's a y squared term and an x
squared term but you see how they have
opposite signs this one's negative this
one's positive that tells us it's a
hyperbola so it's good knowing going in
what type of section we're working with
so let's go ahead and group the Y's
together 16 y squared minus 128 Y okay
I'm going to group the X's together and
I'm going to move the 239 to the other
side so minus 239 same thing we're going
to group these and we're gonna factor
out the leading coefficient this is a
plus in between okay so I'm gonna factor
out the 16 so if I do that that comes
out to Y squared minus and okay let's
see what's 128 divided by 16 let's just
check that real quick okay it's 8 ok so
that's going to be 8y and if we factor
out a negative 1 here we're gonna be
left with x squared minus 2x equals
negative 239 ok so to complete the
square what we're gonna do is we're
gonna take 1/2 of negative 8 which is
negative 4 square it that's 16 but
remember because it's in parentheses
it's actually 16 times 16 that's 256 we
have to add that to the other side you
want to keep that balance the equation
ballots and then here 1/2 of negative 2
is negative 1 negative 1 squared is
positive 1 but really because it's in
parentheses that's a negative 1 so I
have to subtract one from the other side
as well so that comes out to negative
240 and this comes out to
let's see what is that that's 256 so
what is that
that's 16 right okay 16 so now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna factor
this so let's do that we've got Y minus
4 the quantity squared remember is just
half of that middle coefficient we set
it up that way to be a perfect square
trinomial and the same thing here we're
gonna take half of that little
coefficient which is going to be X minus
1 squared K equals 16
with hyperbolas and ellipses you always
want them to equal 1 so to do that I'm
going to divide everything by 16 so it
equals 1 on the right let's just divide
everything by 16 these are gonna cancel
so we end up with Y minus 4 squared
minus X minus 1 squared over 16 this is
over 1 equals 1 so now we're in a
position where we can more easily graph
that hyperbola and analyze it further
check out my video on hyperbolas if you
want to see how to how to graph this one
okay so I hope you're enjoying the
videos if you are you know subscribe to
the channel check out some of my past
videos and I've got some more videos
here coming for you so stay tuned and I
look forward to seeing you in some of
the future videos remember to subscribe
and I'll talk to you soon